hi i'm jason nash and i'm hosting a new  show for GQ called how to be a man you  play your cards right I might let you in  a little man secret  it just sounds kind of where's a man  secretive you got gentlemen  with my lesbian producer Amy will bring  you tips from some of the most  interesting people from around the world  like Michael Ian Black  Casey James Andy Daly Dave Koechner  Andrea Savage Andy Richter and maybe  Sarah Silverman action tips first rule  of fishing no gabbing emotion and me  your host Jason Nash balance your rod  like you know like Oh Raja is like  another word for penis all of this and  more on gqueues how to be a man for more  awesome videos that teach you how to be  a man subscribe to our youtube channel  and follow us on Twitter